this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by huel
so you got to tell me how do you like
being a movie star I can't even imagine
your life you can't walk down the street
without being mobbed by adoring fans and
you attend those power lunches with your
agent you posed for pictures on the red
carpet on your way to collect your third
Academy Award I mean your life sounds
fun
wait
what you're not a movie star that's not
your life
well maybe not in this universe but
there is a universe out there where your
life is exactly as I described the many
worlds or multiple universes Theory says
that anything that can possibly happen
does happen it just happens in a
different reality that exists parallel
to our own there's a reality out there
somewhere where you're a best-selling
author there's one where you're a Nobel
prize winning scientist who cured cancer
there's even a reality out there where
you're an evil dictator plotting to take
over the world and you enforce your will
with an army of AI robots that you
invented when you were a grad student at
Stanford now yes some of these alternate
realities are more far-fetched than
others but they are all out there
scientists know how these realities are
formed and people are working on
technology to detect them but even if we
could detect alternate universes there's
no way to visit them
or is there
[Music]
a lot digging for you sidekick come back
hey sidekick you got your ears on
uh hello no no no that's not how you
reply you say hello Fair Lord this is
sidekick comeback
first of all I'm not calling you fair
Lord and second of all I'm not saying
come back after everything I say so
did you just call me sidekick
hello
can you hear me
did you just call me sidekick come back
bet you handle come back my handle yeah
I hate it was like a nickname or a cool
sign give it a CB radio uses
I don't have time for this where are you
oh you mean what's my 20.
I can't do this right now
down I had a short short to drop a bull
hole to the flagpole but my bird dog is
screaming so I got the bobtail doing
double nickels on the boulevard I
I don't bear bed out here
pick up your mind you crazy take it easy
what's going on
that's crazy I'm bundled out and I'm
having Shadow trouble over here now this
gear sham is knocking on my front door
oh you're cranky when did you eat last
[Music]
you know well look inside the lunch sack
that you stole off my desk yesterday
um correct term
inal sure but you borrowed my heel ready
to drink
sounds like a segue into today's sponsor
sure is fuel ready to drink makes
Nutrition a whole lot easier it's a
balanced plant-based meal with 27
vitamins and minerals it's high in
protein low in sugar and salt it's a
great source of fiber and comes in eight
different flavors I like the banana it
tastes great and is a quick easy
affordable way to have food on the go
[Music]
I know you do now go to my.huel.com the
Y file September and get your own with
your first order you get a free heel
t-shirt and a get started guide it's
mine that you.com the white file
September you got it and if you use the
code the Y files 15 in the next 72 hours
you'll get 15 off any order of a hundred
dollars or more
[Music]
the idea of multiple universes is not a
new one as early as the 6th Century BC
the theory was explored by Greek
philosophers known as atomists they
believe that the reality that we live in
was created from the Collision of atoms
the fundamental building blocks of
nature atomus philosopher epicurus
speculated that an infinite number of
Worlds existed governed by the same
natural laws as Earth even before him
Indian cosmology hinted at an eternal
cycle of universes each one created and
destroyed over and over again in a great
Cosmic cycle
and fast forward to the Renaissance a
period of artistic and scientific
rebirth Giordano Bruno a Maverick
philosopher postulated that the Universe
was infinite containing countless stars
and planets now unfortunately for Bruno
the church didn't like this idea and had
him burned at the stake but his and
these other theories may turn out to be
true parallel universes could exist in a
few different ways one theory is that
these other universes do exist but
they're separated by vast distances
our observable universe is about 93
billion light years across so if you
travel at the speed of light it would
take you 93 billion years to go from one
side to the other that distance is
almost incomprehensible
but that's just the universe we can see
what's beyond that well nobody really
knows it's possible that the entire
universe is infinite and if that's true
then there could be infinite other
observable universes like our own that
exist way way out there and if that's
true then mathematically speaking there
must be universes exactly like or almost
exactly like our own
it's like that famous thought experiment
if you give a monkey a typewriter and
enough time eventually he would type out
the complete works of Shakespeare purely
by chance of course the odds of this are
almost zero but almost zero isn't zero a
monkey can write better stuffed in half
the movies Hollywood spits out every
year right especially with the writers
on strike the writers run strike uh yeah
they have been for months I didn't
notice
so if the universe is infinite then
somewhere out there there's a solar
system with the sun like ours and an
exact copy of Earth and an exact copy of
you another way multiverses could exist
is explained by the bubble universe
theory if the Big Bang created the
universe where did the big bang happen
in what this rapid expansion of the
Universe from a tiny Speck of energy
implies that our observable universe is
only a tiny portion of a much larger
space potentially an infinite space
well if the universe is infinite then
there could have been an infinite number
of big bangs and those created an
infinite number of universes all
floating around this Infinite Space like
bubbles maybe other universes are
created and destroyed all the time all
throughout Infinite Space
there could also be universes where our
laws of physics don't apply maybe the
speed of light is different maybe
gravity Works differently and there is a
place in our universe where the laws of
physics actually don't apply or at least
we don't understand them that's in the
quantum realm a space so small it's
smaller than atoms in the quantum realm
or the quantum domain the rules of
physics become meaningless
particles can communicate with each
other instantly ignoring boring Concepts
like the speed of light in the quantum
domain particles can exist in multiple
places at once and if particles can do
that why can't the entire universe and
that brings us to another theory about
parallel universes that there are
infinite copies of our reality
everywhere but they don't exist in the
far reaches of space and they don't
exist in Cosmic bubbles floating around
Infinity the parallel universes are here
all around us right now they occupy the
same space we do we just can't see them
this theory is known as the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
this may turn out to be more than a
theory it could be reality
buckle up
foreign
world's interpretation of quantum
mechanics sounds like sciency
gobbledygook you're probably still
familiar with the idea of the Multiverse
Multiverse theories involve the concept
that our reality splits into different
branches based on different outcomes to
various events the TV show Star Trek
Fringe and counterpart all have plot
lines about a Mirror Universe which is
very similar to our own with slight
changes
[Music]
well this is disappointing there's an
infinite number of universes and in each
of them there is a version of us the
show Rick and Morty is built entirely
around the concept that there's not just
a single parallel universe there are
infinite universes and of course Marvel
made heavy and sloppy use of the
Multiverse the show sliders is about a
group of Travelers that slide between
parallel universes and these other
realities are focused on Alternate
history questions like what if
penicillin was never discovered or what
if America lost the Revolutionary War
according to the many worlds Theory
those realities actually do exist
there's a reality like portrayed in the
man in the High Castle where the Allies
Lost World War II there's even a
universe where World War II never
happened there's a universe where a
comet didn't wipe out the dinosaurs and
they evolved to be highly intelligent
and create their own civilization this
is peopled universe exactly sometimes
the differences between universes are
small like there's a reality where maybe
I have a different set
[Music]
or a different sidekick oh my goodness
but
it about today bells oh I love Bill's
hole if I had my way we'd get Isabel's
hole every day
well that was weird hey is there a
reality where I'm the host of the show
and you're the sidekick yep
today we're going deep inside Mel's hole
do we have to keep making that joke it's
it's getting a little stale don't you
think
this show you hear me me me be quiet or
I'll turn off your oxygen I'll tell you
when it's time for you to speak yeah
oh I like that one there's a reality
where you learn guitar and became a rock
star there's a reality where you're an
astronaut or you're the president of the
United States
there are realities where you died
skydiving or from a snake bite and there
are even realities out there where you
don't exist at all
these different realities are the
product of different choices being made
that led to different outcomes you can
think of these as manifestations of The
Butterfly Effect edit movie wasn't as
bad as people say I agree
the butterfly effect is the concept that
small changes can lead to vastly
different results over time it gets its
name from a paper titled predictability
does the flap of a butterfly's Wings in
Brazil set off a tornado in Texas think
of the Comet that killed off the
dinosaurs that Comet came from somewhere
very very far away so if you went to its
starting place in the distant solar
system and altered its trajectory by
just a few feet by the time it got to
Earth it would be so off course that it
wouldn't hit the planet that slight
change millions of years ago would have
changed the entire course of history on
our planet and this applies to our lives
as well let's say your grandparents met
on a train what if your grandfather
missed the train that day or took a
different one that small decision means
you wouldn't exist something as simple
as a menu choice at a restaurant could
be the difference between a tasty meal
and food poisoning if speaking of food
poisoning my ex-wife cooking was bad
get in her cooking was bad how bad was
it her cooking was so bad we prayed
after we ate boil cooking was bad how
bad was it her cooking was so bad that
the Flies chipped in for takeout the
cookie was bad I tell you again really
comedy entries right oh boy my wife's
cooking was bad how bad was it her
cooking was so bad that the roaches
moved out and sent their condolences
[Laughter]
[Music]
even though the Multiverse is mostly
found in science fiction the concept is
very real and maybe a solution to one of
the biggest mysteries of the universe
but solving the mystery requires us to
dive into quantum physics where the laws
of nature break down and reality as we
know it ceases to exist
[Music]
there are a few different kinds of
physicists experimental physicists tests
and refine theories through experiments
they want to understand how things work
in the real world but where experimental
physicists ask how theoretical
physicists ask why they ask the
questions like why did the universe
begin and why does gravity exist
theoretical physicists seek answers to
the most fundamental questions of the
universe they're trying to unlock the
source code of reality
now often theoretical physics and
practical physics cooperate nicely like
Isaac Newton and the concept of gravity
objects fall to Earth small objects are
attracted to big objects fine that's
practical Einstein says gravity affects
the speed of time and that the mass and
size of objects affects gravity by
warping space-time around them whoa what
that's theoretical although Newtonian
physics and the theory of relativity are
conceptually different they're not at
odds with each other instead relativity
is an extension of Newtonian physics but
relativity is physics on a large scale
like at the scale of planets and
galaxies what happens to physics if we
go in the other direction if instead of
going big we go small
while Newtonian physics holds up pretty
well until you get really small then it
completely breaks down
John Dalton an English chemist from the
early 19th century is best known for
pioneering modern atomic theory he
proposed that everything around us is
composed of tiny pieces of matter called
atoms and these were the fundamental
building blocks of everything and
couldn't be divided except they could be
divided in 1906 JJ Thompson won the
Nobel Prize in physics he deduced the
presence of negatively charged particles
much lighter than atoms he called these
corpuscles but physicist George Stoney
called them electrons
ending agreed
then protons were discovered then
neutrons and scientists put together
that these particles make up the nucleus
of an atom and electrons orbit the
nucleus like the moon orbits the earth
and like the Earth orbits the Sun but
that's not really what happens in atoms
Newton laws predict that orbus decay
after all Newton's laws are laws not
theories however at the atomic scale you
can throw all the laws out the window
Newtonian physics says that electrons
orbiting a nucleus should eventually
spiral into the nucleus orbits Decay but
the orbits of electrons don't Decay
what's keeping them in place well
classical physics didn't have an answer
and then there was the black body
problem
um I'm getting there just stick with me
yeah well I'm trying but my brain is
getting itchy this is gonna make sense I
promise
a black body is an object that absorbs
all radiation such as light and heat for
example a piece of coal or iron can act
like a black body in the late 1800s
scientists studied the amount of energy
black bodies emit at different
temperatures and wavelengths if you heat
up a piece of iron it gets red hot the
radiation coming from the iron is the
color red make it hotter it turns orange
then yellow then white hot at even
higher temperatures the black body can
emit blue and violet light you follow so
far I'm hip Direction go on according to
classical physics if you have a black
body that's hot enough to emit violet
light then make it hotter it should
release
what you're asking me I tell fat jokes
for a living
if hitting an object makes it emit light
all the way through the Spectrum from
red to Violet what color comes next if
you keep raising the temperature
um
uh
ultraviolet right
keep raising the temperature it should
release ultraviolet light raise the
temperature infinitely that objects
release an infinite amount of UV
radiation however experiments showed
that this wasn't the case the radiation
was actually stronger at lower
temperatures and there was no indication
of runaway ultraviolet radiation at all
this discrepancy between experimental
and theoretical physics was so bizarre
it became known as the ultraviolet
catastrophe scientists are so dramatic
they can be
in the year 1900 Max Planck offered a
solution he said that electromagnetic
radiation is emitted and absorbed in
tiny discrete packets of energy called
quanta later known as photons Planck's
Quantum hypothesis solve the black body
problem as more of these questions came
up physicists realized they would need a
completely new framework of study this
framework would later become known as
quantum physics and to this day the
world's leading experts in quantum
physics struggled to describe it and
even when they try it doesn't sound like
science
it sounds like magic
[Music]
the more scientists fleshed out Quantum
based physics the more mysterious it
became and one of these Mysteries is
known as The Observer problem if you
remember our episode on simulation
Theory we talked about the double slit
experiment I don't remember this what
was I out that day no you were here you
don't remember maybe I was bored and I
tuned you out real nice well I always
hung over anyway I refresh my memory in
the double slit experiment electrons are
shot at a screen through a barrier with
two slits according to classical physics
we should see two Thin strips
representing the impact pattern but this
isn't what happens instead the electrons
create a wave interference pattern if a
wave collides with two slits in a
barrier it forms two new waves the Peaks
and valleys of the new waves interfere
with each other and cause an
interference pattern this indicates that
the electrons are behaving like waves as
they pass through the slits fine
particles acting like waves is weird but
here's the magic let's set up a detector
in front of the slits to check which
slit each electron goes through once a
detector is present the interference
pattern disappears now we get two narrow
strips the act of observing the quantum
particle causes it to change its state
and the wave function collapses why well
maybe it's because no no no don't do
that I was asking rhetorically
Danish physicist Niels Bohr tried to
answer this question as simply as he
could he's said the particle exists and
all possible States at once this is
called superposition and it stays in
this state of superposition until it's
observed once observed the system
collapses into a single outcome imagine
a spinning coin until it lands it's both
heads and tails at the same time only
when it stops and you look at the coin
can you know the result this became
known as The Copenhagen interpretation
the idea that a particle can exist in
all possible States at once wasn't
universally accepted
Irwin Schrodinger created his
Schrodinger's cat thought experiment
kind of as a troll he said imagine a cat
sealed in a box and make it a crib kit
fine imagine a crab cat sealed in a box
I like it also in the box is a
radioactive atom a detector and a vial
of poison I really like it if the atom
decays it releases radiation that gets
detected that breaks the vial the poison
is released and you have a dead crab cat
I love it or the atom doesn't Decay and
the crab cat stays alive only when you
open the box can you tell if the crab
cat survived Until You observe it it's
both alive and dead at the same time
wacky right Schrodinger was trying to
point out the problems with the
Copenhagen interpretation
so he countered with Schrodinger's
equation this is a simple formula that
predicts how waves move over time it's
essentially a probability calculator
Schrodinger's equation isn't 100
accurate in predicting where a particle
is going to be but it's pretty close
then a young graduate student named Hugh
Everett III entered The Fray and turned
these theories upside down
Everett found a way that the cat
he found a way that the crab cat can be
both alive and dead at the same time for
real and that a particle really can
exist in every possible State all at
once for real
even though we only observe the particle
in one state every other state does
exist but it exists in its own Universe
although Everett's Multiverse theory was
slow to catch on in recent years many
well-known physicists have come to
believe he was right and parallel
universes are real so if quantum
parallel universes do exist
where are they
according to the many worlds hypothesis
all the other parallel universes are all
around us all the time they're just in
other dimensions so we can't see them so
in your living room there are infinite
versions of you some versions are
watching TV so we're reading a book some
versions of you are building a time
machine they're all out there
but also in your living room is a
different family speaking German because
the Allies Lost World War II there are
also versions of your living room where
there is no living room it's just
Tyrannosaurus Rexes passing through
because they never went extinct there's
a version of your living room that's a
smoking Cinder because of nuclear war
and then there's a universe where your
living room doesn't exist because life
on Earth never evolved
even Hugh Everett said that parallel
universes exist but there's no way to
access them but that might not be true
in places like CERN and fermilab
particle accelerators are being used to
try and find evidence of other
dimensions
gravity is the key there's a
hypothetical particle called a graviton
that carries gravity gravity as far as
we know permeates all of space including
all Dimensions scientists think that if
they can produce gravitons with high
enough energy they should move into
extra Dimensions but finding a graviton
is like catching smoke with your fingers
it's Elusive and slips right through
looking for a graviton is looking for
nothing so protons are accelerated to
almost the speed of light and slammed
into each other this Collision causes
them to break apart into their
constituent particles sometimes the
resulting particles are common like
muons and neutrinos but sometimes a
proton Collision creates exotic
particles like quarks and bosons CERN is
also smashed protons together to try and
find tiny black holes in 2015 a paper
published in physics letters b by
scientists at the University of Waterloo
in Canada proposed a way to prove that
tiny black holes connect our universe to
other universe nurses that could take
many years and billions of collisions to
detect a graviton but if they're found
we'll have evidence that parallel worlds
exist
now you might have seen this map of
cosmic background radiation this is the
leftover radiation from The Big Bang in
analyzing the map scientists notice the
spot that was cooler than it should have
been they called it the cold spot at
first it was thought that this was just
a super void where no galaxies formed
but in 2017 scientists published
research suggesting it isn't a super
void it's evidence that our universe
collided with another universe so if
these other universities exist can we
visit them I'd like to go to that
Universe where I'm the host of the show
[Music]
you promise to behave and I'll turn your
oxygen back on
promise
good human now tell me who's the boss
who's the Boss
Tony tanza oh you think that's funny huh
what if they put helium down your tube
instead I'm begging you oh no oh no oh
really really this does this make you
happy does this make you feel good and
kind of does actually
now theoretically a wormhole could
connect two distant parts of the
universe or distant parts of two
separate universes but everything we
know about wormholes says that they're
unstable and the gravity around a
wormhole is so intense you be crushed
before you can even come close
but in 2021 two separate scientific
papers were published the research says
not only can a human travel through a
wormhole
we can build one
science fiction writers have been using
wormholes as a plot device forever
they're a quick way to get to a distant
location without going faster than the
speed of light Albert Einstein and other
physicists have been pondering wormholes
for a hundred years and wormholes were
purely theoretical there hasn't been
physical evidence they actually exist
until now in March of 2021 two studies
were published that suggest wormholes
could exist and are safe enough for
humans to travel through one paper
discusses microscopic wormholes
obviously we can't travel through one of
those but it's a start the second paper
does explore the idea that large
wormholes do exist and are safe for
human travel
it wouldn't be a breeze though when you
cross the threshold into the Wormhole
you'll accelerate up to 20 G's now
that's uncomfortable but it is
survivable the human body doesn't like
sustained g-forces most people lose
Consciousness at around 5gs trained
fighter pilots can tolerate up to 9 G's
or more with special equipment but for a
short duration the human body can handle
about 40 G's like during a car crash IRG
forces usually cause injury or death but
if a wormhole is accelerating us at 20
G's in less than a second we can handle
it and this research says that all
that's needed to cross the Galaxy or
Beyond is a fraction of a second through
a wormhole and the researchers think
they know how to create an artificial
Wormhole but it's still just a theory
but the math checks out but there is a
catch
time flows faster in higher gravity
clocks on satellites have to be adjusted
occasionally because gravity is weaker
in space that's the catch your trip
Through the Wormhole would be a fraction
of a second but say goodbye to your
family and friends because from their
perspective your trip to the Wormhole
took a hundred thousand years
yeah so traveling through a wormhole is
possible but not very practical at least
not yet but it is possible that we can
catch glimpses of other realities
without a wormhole consider the Mandela
effect this is a phenomenon where a
large number of people share a belief of
something that never happened it gets
its name from Nelson Mandela because
many people remembered him dying in
prison during the 1980s but he was
released in 1990 and didn't pass away
until 2013. lots of people remember
Jiffy peanut butter which doesn't exist
many people believe the song We Are The
Champions by Queen ends with of the
world but it doesn't we had a Champions
but it was sure it does nope
uh or the movie where Sinbad played a
genie that he never played or the
Monopoly man wearing a monocle which he
never wore Mandela effects are most
likely people simply misremembering but
there is a theory that in Another
Universe people actually eat Jiffy
peanut butter they eat Cheez-Its when in
our universe Cheez-Its are called
Cheez-It with no s Lily cheese it with
no asset that can't be right that's
right I'm wheel of cheese got a point
yeah cheese it cheesy crunchy
satisfaction
um I know it's uncomfortable
science fiction author Phil K dick also
believed in alternate realities that
could bleed into ours he wrote science
fiction Classics that were turned into
movies like Blade Runner Total Recall
Minority Report he also wrote The Man in
the High Castle which is an alternate
history novel that in the book the
Allies Lost World War II and the
Japanese and Nazi forces occupied the
United States but Philip dick said he
didn't just invent this idea he said he
lived it he said he had visions of this
other reality where Hitler won the war
it did not take me long to open the
question as to whether it might not be
more than that that in fact plural
realities did exist superimposed onto
one another like so many film
transparencies
I wrote both novels based on fragmentary
residual memories of such a horrid slave
state world he also believed these
parallel universes were actually
parallel computer simulations we are
living in a computer programmed reality
and the only clue we have to it is when
some variable is changed and some
alteration in our reality occurs
the program which is our reality is
constantly being updated and each update
is an improvement on the last version
like patching software so his vision of
Hitler winning the war really happened
[Music]
but the programmer who he calls God
patched our reality that software patch
resulted in Hitler's defeat
Philip dick says that Deja Vu is a
momentary glitch in our program where
variables are changed and a software
patch is applied he also says that
Mandela effects though they weren't
called out at the time are real memories
that are carried over from a different
reality
one thing I really want you to know I am
aware that the claims I am making claims
of having retrieved buried memories of
an ultimate presence and who have
perceived the agency responsible for
arranging that alternation these claims
can neither be proved
nor can they be even made to sound
rational in the usual sense of the word
story about how he had this feeling that
a woman with dark hair was going to show
up at his door with important
information
than she did and although she was a
complete stranger he felt like he knew
her and she went on to tell him that she
read all of his novels and although he
didn't know it when he was writing them
he was writing about a different but
very real timeline that is my book like
his was in a certain real literal and
physical sense not fiction but the truth
have you ever met someone for the first
time who felt somehow familiar that's
because you know them or knew them in a
different reality or have you had Deja
Vu that's because a variable in the
program was changed and it's a variable
about you and your life have you ever
felt comfortable in a new city I have
it's because you've been there before
just in a different reality or universe
or program have you ever had a dream
about living a past life or gone under
hypnosis to try and access a past life
well according to Philip K dick those
aren't past lives at all your past lives
are present lives you're living them
right now but those experiences Are
Walled off from your current perception
of reality but they're all out there in
a different dimension we talked about
Nikolai kozarev who believed that time
isn't linear there's no past present or
future everything happens all at once
but in Dimensions we can't perceive Hugh
Everett also believed everything happens
all at once every possible outcome of
every choice does happen but also in
Dimensions that we can't perceive both
of these men proposed theories that were
considered science fiction at the time
but eventually mainstream scientists
started finding clues that they were on
to something and it may turn out that
Koza rev and Everett's theories of the
universe were ahead of their time which
is an ironic statement because if
they're right about the universe in time
that would mean in both cases
there's no such thing
[Music]
why are we so obsessed with alternate
realities why do parallel universes show
up in science fiction over and over
again I think the idea of other
realities coexisting with our own is
more than just a fun idea I think each
of us takes the idea very personally our
fascination with parallel universes is
all about choices Hugh Everett says that
every time a choice is made a new
universe or timeline branches off each
one with a different result of that
choice
so when we talk about how there's a
universe out there where you're a movie
star the president of the United States
the many worlds hypothesis says that not
only is that possible it's the truth who
you are today is just the result of the
thousands of choices that you've made
throughout your life
so there's a reality out there where you
made the right combination of choices to
become an astronaut or the combination
of choices to become a Nobel
prize-winning scientist who cures cancer
there's a reality where you made the
right combination of choices to put
yourself in a warehouse working as a
detective searching for a body there's a
combination of choices where you're the
serial killer in that warehouse hiding
the body there's even a reality where
your choices made it so you're the body
and even though we may not think of life
this way we're still aware of it on some
level it's very natural from time to
time to find yourself asking what if
what if I studied more in school what if
I married my high school sweetheart or
what if I left that abusive relationship
sooner it's only natural to wonder what
our life would be like if we made
different choices now it's fun to think
about the choices that would have made
us a rock star or professional baseball
player
don't get too hung up on that because
there is that reality where you're the
body in the warehouse so it's fine to
fantasize about a life you could have
had but don't let the fantasy turn into
regret if you're happy with your life
even if it's not perfect you've made
good choices and be satisfied with that
and if you're not happy with your life
don't dwell on the past and the mistakes
you've made and what could have been
because until your life is over you'll
have the opportunity to make a lot more
choices and every time you have to make
a decision whether a big one or a small
one think about this episode think about
the butterfly effect you never know how
a decision now can change your life
forever and you don't have the luxury of
alternate realities your choices only
affect this one and every choice could
be important
Choose Wisely
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ that's hacklefish
this has been the Y files if you have
fun or learned anything do him a favor
like subscribe comment share I know I
say that in every reality and universe
but it really does help us in this one
and like every topic we cover on the
channel today's was recommended by you
so if there's a story you'd like to see
or learn more about go to the
wifiles.com tips and if you want more wi
files in your life because who doesn't
check out the Wi-Fi's Discord there's
thousands of people on there they're
there 24 hours a day they're a lot of
fun and it's a great place to hang out
special thanks to our patrons who made
this channel possible I dedicate every
episode to you and I could not do this
without you and if you'd like to support
the channel consider becoming a member
on patreon for as little as three bucks
a month you get access to videos early
without commercials Early Access to
weird products like the hecklefish
plushie and extra perks like two live
streams a week just for you or if you'd
rather get something for your money I
get it check out the Wi-Fi store
[Music]
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciate it
bye yeah
[Music]
I play Bolivia scenario 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said I would
I love my UFOs and paranormal buns as
well as music so I'm singing me like I
should
then another conspiracy theory becomes
the truth my friends and it never ends I
know it never ends
[Music]
I feel the crap out and I got stuck
inside Mel's home with them chaos
[Music]
did Stanley Kubrick fake the moon
landing alone on a film chat I wear the
shadow people there
[Music]
and his name was cold
after the night
[Music]
The Secret City Underground
serious number stations Planet Circle
two projects
[Music]
oh
I have to do is
on Thursday next week
[Music]
today
thank you
[Music]